arnaud et frédéric voilà le nom des deux
candidats de cette nouvelle saison de
koh lanta qui cristallise l'attention
des candidats qui à plusieurs reprises
ont décidé de faire alliance pour
éliminer d'autres membres du casting on
a trouvé un terrain d'entente entre les
garçons cas d'anormal jusque là sauf que
les candidats qu'ils décident d'éliminer
sont systématiquement des candidates
voilà le constat de nombreux internautes
qui s'indignent que cette année
particulièrement les stratégies soient
dirigées exclusivement contre les pannes
de l' aventure moi je voudrais pas un
gars sont environ et film une phrase qui
a beaucoup fait parler sur les réseaux
l'an dernier la gagnante alexandre avait
déjà évoqué le sexisme qu'elle
ressentait dans le programme
on est venu montrer qu'on pouvait être
aussi forte que des garçons eux dès
qu'ils font une performance ce sont des
demi dieux et nous il ya toujours une
critique sur quelque chose
des témoignages et des attitudes qui
interroge mais vendredi c'est frédéric
hervé qui ont été éliminés de l'aventuré
berné les aventuriers de la tribu
réunifiée ont décidé de vous éliminer et
leur sentence est irrévocable
comme quoi les fis pourrait bien prendre
leur revanche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi mon frère d'amour il m'a amené un
vrai un vrai ça serait le commence est
maintenant buchta et ses sept mers d'un
c'est lourd non mais sans rigoler c'est
un truc de fou et celle ouvrait ces
nouveaux rêves et vous partez avec un
collant quatre noms comme ce moment il
n'est pas fait que le décor à qu'on a
fini à quoi taper sur le flambeau ouais
mais sur ses vraies à la chaîne nous a
pas aidé mais sûre c'est le tour
montparnasse a dit non mais sans
déconner il
je vous dis c'est la première fois que
l'eau voire flambeau en vrai de kolontar
voilà je vous ferai passer dans public
pendant laquelle vous allez voir c'est
très lourd toi tu es parti à nec
ah ouais bon bah mon avis tu sais quoi
ils vont t'appeler doit encore occuper
on va récupérer le faux moi c'est
vraiment débat bien souvent parce que
comme ce sera de ma faute je te l'offrir
i merci d'accord sûr et certain voilà je
pense qu'il sera libre à plus pour moi
mais il échoue alors les chevilles
colons telle compétition sexiste c'est
vrai que sur les réseaux sociaux y en a
beaucoup qui disent que l'émission était
sexy ce qu'est ce que vous en prie
il faut arrêter de voir du sexisme
partout des à koh lanta c'est l'émission
nos stratégies donc tous les coups sont
permis et autant de filles que de
garçons éliminé cette saison et ça veut
dire passer à dire que quand on est un
garçon peu plus éliminer une fille c'est
n'importe quoi
alors oui alors ce qui a créé la
polémique c'est qu'effectivement arnaud
a dit on fera sauter toutes les filles
avant les garçons et mettez moi parce
que regarder en avant l'excellent
regarder
on est donc plus que six alors quand je
vous regarde il n'y a plus que deux
femmes dans cette équipe rouge ça
devient compliqué pour la gente féminine
ça pour ça qu'aujourd'hui avec maxime on
n'a pas le droit à l'erreur pour garder
notre place au sein de l'équipe
arnaud ont-elles réseau de se dire que
chez les rouges leurs jours sur copé lui
tenir va pas se mentir je suis éliminé
des femmes ça a un côté maxis peut-être
d'un oeil extérieur et ce qui n'est pas
le cas c'est que ça s'est fait deux fait
petit à petit avec des affinités et
vraiment j'insiste là dessus les deux
candidates avec nous sont vraiment celle
en qui en est le plus de confiance quoi
et je pense pas à ce moment là il ne va
pas les éliminer parce qu'ils vont dire
les femmes sont le sexe faible
elles sont mauvaises elles sont nulles
non c'est juste parce qu'ils avaient
créé une alliance entre eux c'est plus
une question de complicité et
d'affinités et c'est pour ça qu'ils se
sont liés entre eux et qu'ils n'ont pas
voulu faire sauter les filles parce que
ce sont les sexes faibles ils sont pas
bêtes ils regardent koh lanta aussi ils
voient bien que les femmes gagnent les
missions que ce soit n'a elle christina
les femmes ont gagné et puis les
épreuves ya des épreuves de stratégie
[Rires]
j'ai fait qu'ils n'étaient pas toujours
bien moqué stomp antoine a dû renoncer à
penser l'épisode de vendredi
non un défi à son très très forte ouais
il faut dire que les filles en fait sur
koh lanta avons leur place ok sssa
disponibles soit fait 42 gador les îles
année un peu le col roulé il a bien
bougé j'ai mangé une coupe à marée basse
je pense pas trop choquer donc je n'ai
pas le seul regard qu'ils venaient
d'aussi longtemps
merci alors au tabac qui fait l'épisode
pas moi c'était top les pièces dans leur
place et il n'y a pas de sexisme dans
koh lanta c'est chacun sa stratégie lé
film nous montre bien l ont bien fait
dégager des mecs parce que dès le départ
ils ont fait une coalition contre elle
et puis du coup il sera très bien mais
il y avait du sexisme volontaire ou pas
est ce que gagne par exemple je n'ai pas
du sexisme est ce que les garçons voilà
se disent on est plus être ensemble on
essaie de faire des les mecs et nanas
kleinert exister a toujours que sakon un
faux pas du tout parce que là c'est une
c ne stratégiques comme les autres il
faut savoir qu'à une saison justement
c'était le contraire s'est-elle fx ont
hérité ne fait une alliance contrôler
les mecs en fait d'accord pas du tout
d'accord avec vous donniez avec tiffany
vire et l'on fit rire et koh lanta vous
n'ont fait que longtemps ça d un poteau
l'année d'après le monde sur verdun
alors virer les filles parce qu'elles
sont des filles ça s'appelle du sexisme
titus y analyser dire explicitement
tant qu'il y aura des garçons je ne
voterai pas voilà contre eux c'est du
sexisme messieurs vous ne pouvez pas
défendre mais le procès on s'excite
pardon mais il est grotesque et j'ai dit
oui parce qu'en fait moi je trouve que
koh lanta c'est sexistes envers les
hommes
les rouges elles sont sexistes envers
les hommes elle va leur faire la peau
leur peau elles sont odieux d une sorte
de de girl power de sororité qui est
tellement pathétique
du coup elle elle enlève parfois les
meilleurs candidats pour garder parce
que ces défis par principe donc excusez
moi moi je trouve que c'est ridicule et
c'est pas du tout sexy alors je vous dis
il ya un truc aussi qui a fait
énormément réagir comme chaque semaine
vous verrez lyon il ya eu la
réunification enfin comme chaque année
et l'ambiance c'est vrai que l été pouye
cette année au niveau de la
réunification
les rouges ont été assez mal accueilli
la cdu rien bah oui barry bonds tuerie
du rib ou ce sont les rouges qu'ils
aperçoivent
regarde toi l'héroïne pure
c'est bien l'air n'est plus un bon
sortait lancé bouclier position de
combat
il y avait des motifs d'espoir
je vends pas de rencontrer cacher le
lyrica s'il vous fait des progrès
hypocrite hypocrite c'est tout ça c'est
vraiment le mauvais accueil tu vois tu
vois vraiment une rivalité elle est
vraiment forte et puis ils font pas
preuve de bon-accueil franchement ça ne
fait pas ça comme ça c'est une
compétition c'est toujours été comme ça
tu veux pas dire ça a toujours été comme
ça dans l'école en retardant les autres
réunification tu vois toujours que les
voilà on les accueille bienveillance et
tout ça élimine bah oui nuit après après
le jeu logique on prend et dit mais
c'est aussi son arrivée en belgique et
son lamento rateront va tous et éliminer
les roues étudiants offre actuelle alors
il ya eu un truc aussi c'est que vincent
ce qu'il fallait ce qu'il fallait
retenir de l'épisode de vendredi c'est
la boulette de vincent le jeune homme de
la tribu jaune aux fins du coffre de son
équipe a révélé trop tôt son secret à
ses compagnons d'aventuré
une mésaventure qui a fait beaucoup rire
les internautes je vous propose de
revoir la séquence regardez-moi sur moi
vous serez tous rue
ou alors oui j'ai une arme secrète en ma
possession que je devais utiliser quand
vous allez prononcer le mot
réunification c'est effectivement une
arme secrète
vous allez pouvoir la jouer est ce que
quelqu'un d'autre aurait trouvé l'armé
secrète de la réunification
chez les jaunes malheureusement non
est ce que ces normes secrète a révélé
au moment de la réunification
non en fait jusqu'au conseil de la
réunification
primo n'y est pas là non pas 100 en un
instant vous venez de perdre le secret
que vous gardiez comment est il attrape
un du monde tire à blanc ça fait déjà
pas une sacoche c'est incroyable ça
quand même s'est passé guillaume insou
c'est le meilleur perso de cette saison
serait un peu naïf et dans le calcul
tout le temps on a vu tout à l'heure sur
l'extrait d'une taxe et de sexy le mec
anticipe qui va garder polémique sur les
réseaux sociaux donc il est obligé de
s'expliquer bah ça fait du bien d'avoir
quelqu'un qui est un peu naïf ça fait
beaucoup d'années saïd et pas du tout
naïve puisqu'il n'a pas éliminer
quelqu'un de son équipe joue les naïves
et non mais n'en croyait mais à la lime
prodigués c'est très élaborée à aux
pensées du coup là c'est plus un secret
donc la vie rallye 3 que vous allez trop
loin
sa cote d'ailleurs c'est vrai que là le
moi je trouve personnellement que le
casting il est très fade et lui c'est
quand même l'un des personnages qui
ressort le plus dommage que aurélien
d'ailleurs qui a été éliminé 15 jours
soit parti maintenant à part lui et
aurait inquiété la cie le trouve très
fade on s'ennuie sur le nord je pense à
mettre un bon koh-lanta est un bon cru
je suis sur scène est un bon cru puisque
les filles vont se révéler puis ça va
faire un an la moitié du jeu et je
trouve que c'est vraiment résolu il ya
des preuves de confort qui a fait
énormément parler c'est cette récompense
qui a été proposé aux aventuriers
regarder je vous propose aujourd'hui
pour ce jeu de confort
une récompense qui va vous ramenez j'en
suis sûr à la maison
[Musique]
je tiens tout de suite à vous préciser
ça c'est une portion en tout cas est un
peu
mathieu vous en rêvez oui j'aurais
effectivement il va falloir se battre
avant mon avis c'est une belle bataille
sport c'est par obligation mais c'est
vrai que c'est un drame à ça qu'on va
arriver à ça bientôt
on